je regrette de t'avoir invités thomas
tuer il est trop beau il est triste on
peut faire et son v6 mais si vous allez
sortir votre bagage culturel moi je vais
être à la ramasse derrière voilà non
mais tu meurs c'est du genre du 10 mai
krivine tchéquie quoi exactement mais je
ne connaissais pas avant kevin c'est
incroyable s'est il a fait un bouquin
qui s'appelle ça te passera avec l'âge
c'est ça ouais c'est ça si à 50 ans
qu'on lui dit ça te passera avec
l'agencé salue pas parce que tu n'as pas
rester lcr longtemps et que ça arrivait
toujours je crains plus jamais qu'on vit
dans une société qui est complètement à
l'envers et dit l'essentiel de la
politique c dominé par le pognon quand
tu vois les les guerres dans le monde au
faite aux dunes la liberté contre le
terrorisme c'est quoi il suffit de
regarder où coule le pétrole et on voit
où sur les troupes américaines enfin je
veux dire en dernière analyse c'est
quand même le business le pognon le
profit qui domine toute la vie mondiale
c'est quand même rentré au pc en 56
l'année de budapest quand même oui mais
j'étais il faut le faire c'est l'époque
où tout le monde est parti en général du
pays
je veux je veux pas être à la ramasse
c'est vrai qu'il est très beau mais
c'est comme ça mais je parle je veux
juste qu'on m'explique c'est quoi la
médina peste jean sa grande fille la
hongrie était sous un régime à mon avis
il s'appelait communiste qui n'étais pas
communiste qui était stalinien il ya une
un vol populaire pour dégommer les
bureaucrates qui dirigeait ce pays et
l'armée rouge de moscou est arrivé est
intervenu à écraser la révolte il ya eu
des centaines de morts
on a déjà beaucoup de gens qui ont
quitté à l'époque le parti communiste
parce que c'était la trahison des idéaux
du communisme et c est ça recommence et
en 68 à prague pareil avec l'arrivée des
troupes communistes sanctions il ya
beaucoup de gens que ça des cils et qui
était communiste après la guerre
j'ai adhéré au communisme parce que je
croyais au communisme la défense des
travailleurs etc et au début je croyais
pas tout ce qu'on manque mais l'idéal
communiste au départ c'est magnifique
bien ça ne te dirai c'est pour ça que je
viens ces lignes je le garde mais c'est
une utopie par un exemple
soviétique c'était une caricature moi je
m'en réclame pas du tout là le vrai
communiste il existe tout ça dans les
monastères house
approche des biens seulement ce qui
fonctionnait dans les violences dans les
boîtes de partout aussi l'on a chez
nikko am et le communisme sexe
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu